hallo leute ich es wieder roman wallner
und willkommen zu einem neuen video von
mir das sagt doch immer will be oder
leute ich sage euch der dezember wird
es ist nämlich so dass ich auch zu dem
klub gehöre der versuch im dezember
jeden tag ein video hochzuladen und ja
ich glaube es ist eigentlich unmöglich
wenn man die videos selbst schneidet und
jeden tag dreht und schneidet und dreht
und schneidet und dreht und schneidet
das hatten in der geburtstagswoche doch
schon spaß gemacht zu diesen druck zu
haben so jetzt muss ein video kommt
jeden tag ansonsten verfallen man dieses
was haltet ihr schon mal von meinem
slawen outfit schön löchern im knie
damit man auch friert
katja krawiec musikvideo wenn allen so
kalt ist und man sich warme gedanken
machen möchte youtube ein react to von
unsympathisch tvn react to von crafter
ein react to von ungespielt ein react
uhr von haaren ein reaktor von crafter
richtigen sachen dem start im dezember
da wars acht coco lebendiger als das
leben ja ja ja ja man sie perfekt 3
kommt im dezember lag die erste deutsche
netflix serie die international gezeigt
wird konzerte album releases
durchschnittlich also sehr wie viele
alben release noch mehr als filme kommen
ich weiß noch nicht ganz so wo dieses
format hinführt welcher promi hat er
nach gleichen tag wieder allergrößte
promi der welt geburtstag am 24 dezember
stephanie meyer riet ihm also wenn das
nicht mal ein spannendes video ist oder
ja genau dieses videos scheiße ich muss
mir echt noch überlegen was ich
überhaupt aus diesem format machen
möchte irgendwie hat es noch kein vorne
und hinten und kein garnichts
ich werde mich fürs nächste mal so
richtig schön strukturiert dran machen
und man richtig planen ja versprochen
wir sehen uns dann in diesem video
denkt dran leute im dezember kommt jeden
tag 1 aktiviert die glocke damit ihr
auch kein verpasst und abonniert doch
meinen instagram account und meinen
total count ich bin wirklich sehr lustig
und ihr gibt es auch andere videos und
hier könnt ihr nicht abonnieren
und es tut mir leid für diese folge ich
hoffe er dass ein bisschen spaß
ich konnte euch ein bisschen von eurem
alltag herausziehen und ich muss etwas
essen gehen sonst sterben
bis dann